here tonight right now to perform one of  her biggest hits Cher  sher took the stage at the 2017  Billboard Music Awards to play two of  her biggest hits and accept the coveted  icon award  [Music]  [Applause]  at 71 share is hot as ever check her out  in this year embellished creation yes  those are pasties and here's more  classic share big hair leather jacket  and sexy thigh highs I'm 71 yesterday  and I can do a 5 minute plank ok just  saying after slaying her performance  cher accepted her award and paid tribute  to her mom when I was really young my  mom said you're not gonna be the  smartest you're ugh be the prettiest  you're not gonna be the most talented  but you're gonna be special the crowd  went nuts for cher but no one quite like  Celine Dion who led us sing-along  backstage and praised the diva in front  of et cameras  [Applause]  [Music]  you